the spinner is that little that little
circle that little wheel of dots that
sort of spins around in the video window
when all of a sudden we've run out of
video to play we have not sent the video
to your computer fast enough the
buffering circle is my nemesis it may be
one of the most unwelcome animations on
the Internet the biggest problem that
we're trying to attack today is how do
we get rid of the spinner how do we make
it so that as you're watching a video
it never stops until you get to the end
and it's it's a big challenge it's it
has a lot of different dimensions and
there's so many things that can go wrong
and some of them are under our control
and some of them are not under our
control the buffering strategy to
youtube videos is different depending on
where you watch them in some cases the
video you'll start to download it and
off it goes in other cases you download
it in pieces like it sliced bread in
general we prefer to download in pieces
because it lets you adapt it means that
you can decide that things are great and
give people a high quality video or you
can decide that things aren't going to
not going so well and you could
downgrade and try to make the playback
smoother the spinner looks the way it
does it's there just to at least to give
you some notion that we're still trying
but we don't spend a lot of time
figuring out how to make it look nicer
we spend more time figuring out how to
make it go away
spinner itself is actually it's a Jif
it's a chip sitting there yeah it's just
is just sitting there going round and
round and round well it depends YouTube
videos play in so many places there are
many different versions there are JPEGs
there are CSS animations there are flash
animations when someone uploads a video
to us we then take that video and we
create a whole bunch of different files
out of it and those files represent
different levels of quality different
levels of bandwidth and you can see this
if you use the YouTube player you have
that little selector which says you know
720p 480p 360p 240p those are all the
different files there are some one
that's for example if you shot a video
on your phone and it's very very small
there's not much gained by making one
that's very
very large so there are some constraints
in that way in addition to those files
those files themselves are chopped up
into small pieces so for each of those
files we have these pieces that
represent a couple seconds of video the
actual size can vary and that's
something we play around with from time
to time to see if it has any impact on
the reliability of the streaming one of
the challenges that we have to deal with
is getting to all these different
devices that support different formats
and so we actually we have them we have
these as mp4 s you know using the h.264
codec we have these as WebM files with
the vp8 and vp9 codecs we also have
these as 3gp files with some other
mpeg-4 codecs to reach older phones so
not only have you got all of these
videos being uploaded every day you're
then turning them into all these
different resolutions and all these
different file formats we have a pretty
large set of formats and resolutions
that we support at the end of the day so
when I upload this video how many
different formats will it be existing in
that's a really good question and
personally I've almost lost count it's
it's certainly a couple dozen Google has
a lot of different data centers around
the world and we also have you know a
network of caches that sort of deployed
with you various ISPs around the world
so as you as you're sort of dividing up
as you're uploading this video creating
all these different formats chopping
those formats up into pieces then you're
putting each of those videos in whatever
data center that may happen to have
space we're making a couple of replicas
to make sure we don't lose it and then
over time as people watch the video it
will get sort of it will get further
distributed to different places so that
it's close to where the people are
watching it it's pretty amazing isn't it
it's pretty fun it's a pretty big system
it's one of the cool things about
working here is it's that there aren't
many systems like it in the world so
there's any host of things that can go
wrong when we're trying when we're
trying to play a video you know it could
be that you're using your computer and
your computer is doing a lot of
different things at the same time it
could be that you're on a Wi-Fi network
that is kind of like a little bit weak
like especially imagine you're at a
hotel and you know hotel Wi-Fi is let's
the undertow
bad it could just be that there's a lot
of activity going on in your ISP and in
your neighborhood it could be that no
one in your area has ever watched this
video before so we don't have a copy
close by and we have to go to a faraway
server to get it the key message here is
just that there's an inordinately but
some of which we can't control directly
and so the best we can do and the thing
we feel very compelled to do is work
around these problems to the best we can
and make them invisible to you this is
why we chopped the video up into small
pieces the thing that you connect with
gathers those pieces and puts them in
order so they can play back in sequence
as you're watching the video it's you
know it's getting the next piece and the
next piece and it's looking a couple
pieces ahead well they don't have to be
in order YouTube videos it can be broken
into pieces and then delivered out of
order or also you could break them up so
that the audio is in one piece and that
the video is in another and so then when
you when you watch them the thing that
you're watching puts them back together
as it gets to each piece its observing
how fast it was able to retrieve that
piece it's like I got this HD piece and
it downloaded really quickly so I can
keep getting HD or it might say the HD
pieces are starting to come in slowly
and I'm not going to be able to maintain
that if I keep asking for HD eventually
I know the user is going to watch the
video faster than I can get the video
and you're going to have that spinner
and so then I would say for the next
piece I'm going to go get the 480p piece
or the 360p piece instead to make sure
that the video keeps going on
uninterrupted and of course we do the
reverse as well it could be that you're
watching the video at 360 P but we
noticed that it's really fast and we say
okay you have a really fast connection
next time I'm going to upgrade you to HD
behind the scenes magic you don't have
to do anything and we give you a better
quality when you see the buffer spinner
we retry we'll try to get another video
that we think might play more smoothly
YouTube should just work and you're
welcome to make choices as they're
presented but you shouldn't have to it's
really up to us to try to make the video
play as as best it can and what we would
like to do is give you not just one
that's adequate
one that's beautiful that's that's HD
that has great sound and that's our goal
and we should bring that to you you
shouldn't have to ask this is our
responsibility to make better and we're
not done until no one ever sees that
spinner and people still see that
spinner yeah we we collect the data we
monitor the forums we know it's still
happening and we're constantly tuning
and investigating and trying to figure
out okay if people are still seeing the
spinner why does it have something to do
with the type of network they have does
it have something to do with the country
they're in does it have something to do
with the video they're watching the
relationship from people's device to the
Internet is probably the one that's
fraught with the most variation one of
the big challenges is the fact that
we're trying to support a huge range of
different types of environments you know
everything from someone watching a video
on their phone in India to watching a
video on a new 4k TV with Gigot with a
gigabit connection in the u.s. do I feel
that people blame me for YouTube's
performance issues I think they do blame
me for you too performance issues but I
think that they're correct I don't think
there's any approach out there that's
been suggested or any technique that's
been out that out there that is probably
not part of our bundle of tricks the
burden of proof on YouTube is to work
and if you're not getting if the video
doesn't play as you wish then you should
ask why
we make sense for us to walk in and say
guys you know I'm feeling like we ought
to put a higher weight on something even
if I were to feel that we ought to put a
higher way than one watch 26 27 zeros
and then a few ones for every single
character that is incredibly wasteful